this morning russia claims it has
destroyed ukrainian army command posts
in eastern and southern ukraine it also
says russian warplanes struck a weapons
and equipment base in northeast ukraine
the attacks come as president biden says
the u.s will buy and donate new advanced
surface-to-air missiles to kiev
inocencio is in the ukrainian capital
where one man is inspiring millions of
people to donate millions of dollars to
buy more
[Music]
is a weapons former comedian and
politician now turned founder of one of
ukraine's biggest crowdfunding
foundations in this war my job was
about how to make people smile
now i live in um
in times when
i don't want to make people smile
uh
i want to unite people just for revenge
his office feels like a military command
post upstairs a young social media team
works to inspire their countrymen for
ever more donations
it's working the foundation just raised
20 million dollars in three days from
the people to buy four advanced drones
for the military the drones known as
bairakhtar drones from turkey were
pivotal in ukraine's early defense we
can do something really important for
our army everybody think that it's
impossible but we did it they even
inspired a viral folk song
and in a supportive twist the drone
maker this week said it'll give free to
ukraine's war effort for free
i was really crying because we saved 15
million united states dollars and now
we're trying to choose some other
way to spend the money
the need doesn't end this past week
russian airstrikes killed more than
three dozen people across ukraine
including an apartment in kindergarten
in kiev hitting close to home
two days ago russian missile destroyed
kindergarten where my daughter
was
growing up two years the foundation
keeps churning equipment out infrared
binoculars long-range scopes and small
drones on one level
on another bulletproof vests energy
drinks and medical kits these from
ukrainians in chicago ready to roll to
the front lines
pratulla confesses this war has changed
him forever
when do you think you can go back to
being a comedian do you think you can
i think never
i have no humor now
but he does keep hope to rebuild cities
and reconnect families if ever this war
might end
for cbs saturday morning raymie
innocencio
right